let's jump into this first story from
timcast.com oklahoma oklahoma governor
signs bill making performing an abortion
a felony the law grants an exception for
abortions performed to save the life of
the mother
governor kevin stitt signed senate bill
612 on april 12th the measure makes it a
felony to perform an abortion except to
save the life of a mother anyone who
performs an abortion could face up to 10
years in prison and a 100 000 fine the
law goes into effect in 90 days quote we
want to outlaw abortion in the state of
oklahoma stitt said during a signing
ceremony i promised oklahomans that i
would sign every pro-life bill that hits
my desk and that's what we're doing here
today women who seek or receive an
abortion are not subject to criminal
charges under the bill now my question
is
roe v wade still exists right
so what's going on
well i mean
first of all i'm never satisfied so
the bit there about except to say the
life of of the mother i'm a little
i want to read more into that because i
i don't think that exception should be
there because
usually when you look into that you find
that well
saving the life of the mother what
they're really talking about is uh if
the mother is in emotional distress then
she can still get the abortion so you
have to look into that because in
reality in reality
there is never a need for an abortion to
save a mother's life it never actually
happens but putting that aside um i
think what we see here is the republican
party and this is like a shock for those
of us who grew up we're so used to
republicans being milk toast and
and uh cowardly and many of them still
are but we're starting to see in some of
these states oklahoma florida like the
republicans are actually going on
offense which is exactly what you have
to do is is go on offense and try to try
to enact laws according to your own
value system rather than always playing
defense and if you believe that abortion
is the murder of a child
then of course you're gonna do
everything within your power to outlaw
you're not going to sit around and say
well the supreme court has spoken it's
the murder of a child i think i think
there's some dep i think there's a
semantic issue here as well so you said
there's there's never a you said there's
never a circumstance to having to
perform an abortion to save the life of
the mother yeah
so do you want to just elaborate on that
well
usually you hear about this uh abortion
to save the life of the mother thing and
these these especially late term
abortions and um so what i guess you got
to use an example so like one example
would be let's say the mother
is is pregnant and then has some sort of
medical complication um
cancer or something like that and and
you have to end the pregnancy especially
later in
later term
well yeah you end the pregnancy to save
the mother's life you don't have to kill
the child first though you you can
deliver the child at least try so you
could yeah you can at least attempt it
so
we we i i could submit and agree that
there are times when to save the
mother's life you have to end the
pregnancy
especially in later terms
um but you don't have to killing the
child is an extra step
that is not necessary you can deliver
the child
and in many of these life-saving
quote-unquote life-saving abortions you
have children that could be delivered
and you set them up to the nicu and
there's there's a good chance that the
child could still survive yes there's
children that survive at like 21 weeks
at this exactly yeah yeah so viability
continues to get lower and lower so so
just just to clarify uh because i
mentioned a semantic issue is uh what
you're saying is they should at least
try to save the life of the child if
yeah because abortion here's what
abortion is abortion is the direct
intentional killing
of the child there is never a time when
you need to commit the direct
intentional killing of the child to save
the mother so if there's if late term
abortion doesn't make any sense you know
third trimester abortion is completely
nonsensical because the child can
survive right exactly because in the
late term abortion you're still
delivering the child there's still a
delivery that happens
but you kill the child first why do you
need to kill the child so just deliver
the child just to further clarify
in in the instance where there is a
severe abnormality and the baby likely
will not survive and the mother likely
will not survive a birth you're saying
that if they were to
deliver the baby or maybe a c-section
they can at least try to save both is
what you're saying absolutely there's no
reason why you wouldn't try to do that
unless you're just saying that well the
child's life doesn't count he has no
moral worth which is what our laws say
right now in most states is that the
child's life he has no moral worth we
don't have to try to save him that's
interesting yeah and i want to mention
this because i basically said something
along those lines on the last episode
where we did discuss this there are
procedures that will be referred to as
abortions in order to make the argument
that abortion is ever medically
necessitated and it's just not true so
if there is an operation that is
required to save the life of the mother
but that poses a risk to the life of the
unborn child that is not the same thing
as an abortion uh and there's a
principle known as the principle of
double effect where you're trying to do
one thing and there might be a negative
unintended consequence but it's not the
same thing morally as intending to do
the secondary thing which can result
yeah that's what i was getting to is
that that's a good point because the
cancer example is one where maybe the
mother is diagnosed with late stage
cancer and you have to you know chemo or
something and and there's a chance that
that will kill the child well if you're
not directly and intentionally killing a
child you're just you're doing a a
procedure to try to save the mother's
life and tragically the child dies in
the process that is not an abortion well
that's the same thing too when it comes
to to the medical procedure because
we're talking about euthanasia
specifically ending uh you know
long-term care or making people
comfortable as they die i mean there's a
big difference of intentionally you know
injecting a lethal dose of an opiate to
end somebody's life or some sort of a
solution that would kill them versus if
somebody's already on you know hospice
and they already are their organs are
running at 20 30 40 percent capacity and
then you give them some sort of an
opiate and their heart just simply
cannot process cannot take it the liver
cannot process the drugs so then they go
into organ failure and die are you then
going to say that the hospice nurse you
know murdered the woman did she go in to
kill her is that is did she euthanize
her no you'd go well she did what she
could to make her comfortable and that
then she died and responded differently
and so what we always do is we put a lot
of things in umbrellas it's like the
lgbtq community they keep adding letters
to decide what's involved in our group
abortion has an expansive definition
where sometimes you've even heard of
steel births counted as abortion if they
force you know if they force the the the
delivery and it's a stillbirth they go
oh well it was an abortion because the
baby was dead and you know that's not an
abortion that baby was dead so they
forced the delivery but it allows them
to it allows them to umbrella to justify
the means and that's a constant issue
that i see and i want to make one little
point here like you were saying earlier
the problem with the the idea of
necessity uh in abortion for for women
to save their lives i mean if you look
at what's happening in canada right now
with with the euthanizing uh argument
they want to be able to euthanize people
who suffer with depression with
schizophrenia with anxiety they're
pushing themselves they already do in
northern europe and it's really
devastating they actually
they actually put a young woman to death
so you were depressed a few years ago
and it's really yeah she wanted to be
euthanized she can kill your baby i'm
depressed i don't want to have a baby so
where do you where do you draw the line
of what's what's uh putting the mother's
life in jeopardy i think matt you got
some nuance that is often uh left out of
the conversation too because you know my
my line of questioning was certainly
there's going to be some circumstance
where the mother and the baby's life are
both in jeopardy
but the term abortion i think is often
just meant to imply
taking the baby out afterwards it's sort
of uh
there's no there's no real thought to it
so when you explain that well now i
understand
if there's circumstance and correct me
if i'm wrong in which the mother and the
baby might both likely die
well if they have to remove the baby
they can try and save it right and and
our in our this is it's really a miracle
the way that our technology has
progressed that now you can deliver a
baby at 21 weeks and and oftentimes the
child will still survive and this is
we're going to get to a point where
eventually we get to the point with the
technology where a child can survive
outside of the womb at any stage
have a federal rule right we have the
14-day rule for research
um where you can
where scientists researchers can
uh basically take um
you know a fertilized embryo and grow it
in a lab and you can grow it up to 14 i
not 14 weeks i have 14 days you can grow
up to 14 days
and then you can't grow it in the lab
anymore
um because then you're experimenting on
humans essentially isn't it interesting
how they've decided you're human at 14
weeks but before that 14 days or 14 days
but before that it's a 14-day rule so
you're not allowed to experiment after
14 days um so so it counts as life in a
petri dish days 14 days in the womb it
would knock out that's right by the law
what i'm really interested in
i'm sorry i just gotta ask let's say
we're at 18 weeks pregnancy and there's
a medical complication where they're
like if we don't you know end this
pregnancy the baby and the mother will
die within a week or two i mean i i know
it's an edge case but i'm sure there are
circumstances what would your
perspective be on something like that
well this is where you get into it and
it is important to to emphasize it is
it's like a friend
we're talking about a small percentage
of cases and and the vast majority of
abortions have nothing to do with saving
money but in these kinds of like
incredibly devastating situations then
you have to fall back on these kind of
philosophical distinctions like double
effect um and in a situation like that
then maybe you know you might perform a
life-saving procedure on the mother
that's like almost
certain to result in the death of the
child but that's not your intention it's
not what you're trying to do i see it
right so it's
that and that's the distinction and
sometimes you get to the real fringe
cases it does feel like you're splitting
hairs but you're actually not because
the principle is really important and
well there aren't cases where women
eschew
radiation treatment for cancer because
they're pregnant and they don't want and
that's and that's heroic but it's like
that's heroic but we would also i'm not
going to sit here and say that if a
mother needs radiation that that that i
think
she should be morally required to forgo
it that that's a heroic thing and i have
a lot of respect for i think that you
could still buy principal double effect
get the cancer treated agreed right
yeah did you elaborate on double effect
already
yeah so so the idea behind the principle
of double effect is if you are
attempting to do something which is good
but there is an outcome that is bad
which can result from it but that bad
outcome is not your intention you're not
morally culpable for it in the way that
you would be if you were just going out
of your way to ensure that outcome but
just to clarify
not as much as you would be there's a
lot of good intent well i think what i'm
saying not as much as you would be i
want to be really clear here because i
would have to i would have to re-read up
on this principle again i i think it's
actually the case where you're not
culpable yeah this is well this is the
old tram car yes hypothetically you guys
know that but right of course we got to
clarify this because i mean
i i think there are some really dumb
communists certainly there are really
bad ones but who are thinking you know
if i take the farm from the farmer and
give it to the farmhands i'll be doing
great and then everyone starves to death
it's like they're responsible for that
but here's the difference
doing something which is intrinsically
immoral which is stealing somebody
else's property so let's get it to the
the i see i see what you're saying the
tram thing it's it's if i remember
correctly it's like a thought experiment
where there's a train coming down the
track and there's like five people tied
to the track and you're standing next to
the switch and you could pull the switch
and send the train on a different track
but there's one guy on that track and is
it okay to pull the the uh the lever and
send it off to save the five people and
the answer is
yes because your your intention is to
save the five you're not trying to kill
the one guy um on the other hand though
i disagree with that yeah i disagree
really yeah no no because that's if
you're like i know my action will kill
somebody but i'm going to do it because
i think one that's utilitarianism yes i
don't think i think that's the argument
right it's a utilitarian argument i
think a better argument is just
literally what we're talking about with
a medical procedure a doctor says
this patient has a a tumor next to an
artery if i don't remove it they'll die
in a year but there's a risk they die in
the in the process and they say i'm
gonna i'm gonna intervene if the person
dies we're not gonna be like you
murderer we're gonna be like yeah that
you're trying in the train car situation
if somebody pulls that lever to save the
five not at all intending to kill the
one guy
are we going to send that guy to jail
for murder i mean i think clearly we
would not that's a good point too but
man is that scary and so the difference
is like i wouldn't be that one guy man
yeah but the thing is what if there was
no lever to pull and instead of pulling
a lever you just threw another person in
front of the train to stop it from
hitting the other five now that would be
that would be murder yeah so that's
that's pretty would you agree that's the
problem
yes i would i would say so again not not
an expert on this but i've also heard
the thought experiment put that way what
if there's just a very rotund individual
who you can push in front of the trolley
they'll stop it i think that's a
different question i think that's a
great question
as far as i'm aware i think that's a
different situation yeah i i i don't
think it's a perfect analogy but i do
get what you're saying i think the issue
with the trolley problem is that
there's a guaranteed outcome of five
people dying
or
one move which is a binary which is you
know uh five people dying or the binary
you taking action which kills that one
person
most people when polled say they would
not pull the switch because you are
choosing to kill someone to save five
people
i don't i don't know if i agree with
that analogy um simply because i think
you know it's an issue of like an
officer a cop he he
you know he sees someone draw a weapon
and start pointing it at children so he
pulls his gun out and says drop it and
fires
the bullet goes through the guy's
shoulder and then hits someone behind
him severely injuring him we're not
gonna you know we're gonna say in
defense of others this is actually an
affirmative defense in court cases like
we have with kyle rittenhouse that
you're not responsible
for what's behind the person when you're
acting in defense of yourself for others
so i think it was specific uh specific
circumstance but in the instance where
kyle was attacked they were saying it
was reckless endangerment because richie
mcginnis was close to him and the bull
could have gone through and hurt him but
ultimately the court decided no he can't
be responsible someone was threatening
his life and he took action to protect
himself
i think that's kind of a better way to
look at it i suppose yeah i mean not to
get too into the weeds with the trolley
problem but i think there's a very good
argument to be made that when you pull
that lever your intention is not to kill
any individual person it's to divert the
train from hitting those five
and it would be morally different if you
actually had a vendetta against that one
person laying on the track and your
intention was to kill them because that
would tell us a about your future
behavior b what your decision-making
process is whether you're dangerous and
see whether you are actually intending
to kill someone but i disagree because
you know the outcome is guaranteed death
what we're talking about is an outcome
where there's a possibility of it and
it's you're you're trying to avoid that
but
the guys
what i think is most interesting about
the trolley problem is that uh
the contemplation of it itself is like
the fallacy that we have control over
everything around us you know that we
think that just because there's a
problem that means that we have the
capability of solving it in some
thorough and appropriate way and we
don't i mean you know don't pull the
lever don't kill anybody sometimes bad
things happen
can i just say one thing about the
oklahoma thing which is um governor
stitt doesn't have control over a large
part of his state right right native
american reservations have their own
uh rules and they have their own rules
according to the federal government
so
any native american reservation could
open a casino abortion clinic
and have that combination they could do
the combo they can do whatever they want
and there would be absolutely no ability
for the governor to stop that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you